happy monday everyone how you all doing
you know it's good because it's a goody
bag day
um and so i'll get to what you have in
your hands
um in this lecture um
today so we've been we've been talking
about
these things for a while now right we've
built up an understanding
of the stamp and the basis and and then
we understood how to talk about it like
in terms of the planes
and the symmetries and then we shined
x-rays on it
and now we're going to start taking them
all apart and so
so no don't be sad don't be sad
because because actually that's more
real
that's more real and that's what we'll
talk about today so what
what our plan is is you know so today
we're going to start creating defects
in the perfect order that we've had so
far
um and and in your goody bag you have a
defect generation
machine which we'll talk about um and
then
on and and so today we're gonna we're
gonna talk about one kind of defect
that's a point defect and then on
on wednesday we'll talk about line
defects and then we'll just mess the
whole thing up
and we're going to make it amorphous so
that's
that's where we're going and beyond that
if you want to know more about where
we're going
there's the concept map up there for
exam
3 which again you know we don't pick
these dates so this date came later
um uh in the semester that we wanted but
uh it's that's what it is i think it's
all the way up in
early december um uh but i'm
because of of the fact that there's a
thanksgiving
holiday in between and there's one topic
here we have to start before the exam
it's not here because it won't be on the
exam but
we're going to start polymers but won't
be on the exam i'm going to spend the
whole lecture before exam three
just reviewing for exam three because
we're gonna have that thanksgiving break
and all that so that's what
that's what's not listed here these are
just the topics that are covered
on exam three okay good if anyone has
any questions please do let me know
the concept map now the thesis
of 3091 you have seen in multiple
different ways i have tried to convey to
you that
the electronic structure of atoms
is is the key to life it's the key to
chemistry it's the key to understanding
um and and within that you get things
like this which is what we've been
talking about recently like composition
and arrangement right that's these
crystals that's these different
bcc fcc okay um
and then the chemistry you put inside
but you see the other thing about it is
defects
yeah because the thing is that that
defects
which is the topic of today and
wednesday they are absolutely
crucial for understanding the properties
if
if they're there and i just told you
they're always there the question is how
much are they there
right um and and so so if you don't know
about defects
if you don't know about defects then you
really
cannot fully understand properties
there is a very strong correlation
between the two
and that's why we have to talk about
them we have to understand them
now i love this quote from colin
humphries he said crystals are like
people
it is the defects in them which tend to
make them interesting
yeah and and that's actually really true
because defects
right defects sound you know i don't
want to defect no
actually oftentimes you do want defects
sometimes you don't yeah so there are
some kinds that are kind of like maybe
not things you want in your crystal and
then there are other kinds that actually
you are
engineering purposefully to be there
either way you got to understand them
right and that's what we're doing today
because i'm tight so
you know if you take this three layer we
talk about graphene it's a one
atom thick material pretty cool every
atom's on the surface
all right here's another example of
what's called a 2d material
why it's not 2d but it's called a 2d
material because it gets you like you
know more publicity on your work
this is molybdenum but this is
molybdenum disulpha it's really cool
material it's three atoms thick
so it's kind of like 2d ish right yeah
but see that's the model
that's the model this is reality this is
react
how do you see how do we see atoms like
this
that's a real picture do we use
x-rays no what do we use to see atoms
that well
electrons electrons are our light right
that's what we're using this is an
electron picture
electron and if you do that you can see
individual atoms and look at that
there's there's places where atoms are
missing all over the place
that's reality that's reality
and those where you have one atom
missing
or where you have one thing that is
localized and disruptive to the
regularity of the lattice
that's called a point defect so let's
write that down that's the one
that we're talking about today so the
point defect
point defect is
where you have a localized
localized disruption
in the regularity regularity
the periodicity the repeating of the
lattice
and and it could be on or between we'll
we'll see this on or between
sites right it could be
a defect that is like you see here
there's an actual atom missing
what could be something that maybe
you've got in there in between sites
but either way it's a it's a disruption
that's localized to a point or almost a
point and so it is
because in tight that you can see that
if we just make these disruptions in
something
illumina we talk about alumina all right
mirror is aluminum has
really strong lattice energies so it's
like
it's like sandpaper oh it's also
toothpaste
it's in a lot of stuff aluminum is a
great but look at this
that's alumina with almost no defects
it's got still got some
you can never get rid of them all but
here it is when i purposely engineer the
defects in aluminum and i put a little
titanium or iron
or here's it when i put chromium so you
can there's one property
where the localized disruption and it's
not a lot as we'll see
the localized disruption changes the
properties
that is key that's just color
right this applies to most properties of
materials
and so you know so this this first one
the point defects that we're talking
about today
you can kind of think of those as zero
dimensional um because
they're they're localized you know they
don't really go off in a line they don't
go off in a plane
or a volume and you can have defects
that are that cover all of those
possibilities but these are points all
right this is this is
what the word localized means here okay
okay now in this class we're not going
to cover all of them
but we will cover these two today this
one on wednesday
that one and and that'll give you enough
of a sense of the role of defects and
how to think about defects and crystals
right so this is how we think and
classify
defects okay now the four so now we're
going to point defects now the four
there are different types of point
defects that can happen
the one that you saw here is is a
certain one
that's called a vacancy it's because
there's an atom that's vacant
so you literally just lost an atom
somewhere
in there okay now that that's a vacancy
and that's that can that
always exists um but you could also have
taken something
like one of the atoms that's already in
there maybe an aluminum or an oxygen
that's in the lattice and you could
substitute something
in place of that that's another why is
that a point defect because
i didn't like i didn't like tear
something out no but you changed
the regularity localized disruption and
regularity so if i put something else in
for aluminum
that's a point defect right and again
now go back to here
you can see it here so we classify these
right there's a vacancy
which is an atom missing um there's
there's what's called an interstitial
which is an atom that goes in between
the other atoms here it's a
self-interstitial so it's the same type
of atom
and these are this is where you have a
different type of atom in between
and this is where you have a different
type of atom as well those are both
called impurities
and i will talk about those uh all today
we're gonna start and focus a lot of our
attention on the vacancy
and that's what i want you to use this
goodie bag to understand is the
vacancies
okay vacancies why do vacancies happen
what are vacancies to understand
vacancies
in crystals we have to talk about this
guy
and uh this guy
was brilliant this i'm sure you know
his name is fonte yeah it's written
right there
svante arrhenius arena studied in the
late 1800s so many different things
and made so many contributions that it's
almost hard to catalog he was
brilliant and and you know he won the
nobel prize in chemistry for his work on
electrolytes
but he also worked on immunology he was
the very first person
in the late 1800s to come up with a
model
for global warming and the role of co2
in the temperature change of the planet
and his predictions were actually pretty
darn good
he was brilliant and one of the things
that he did
is he observed what it were called
activated processes and how they
depended on temperature
and so we have this equation that i need
to talk about today and it's going to
come back
so we're going to talk about this
equation which is the arrhenius equation
that relates the rate of some process to
the temperature and the activation
energy
for that process so we got to talk about
what all that means all right
um now uh we will we will be using this
we're to today we're going to use it to
think about
concentrations of vacancies in a crystal
which follow
arrhenius-like behavior
right um and but then we're going to
come back to it when we go into reaction
kinetics
in a couple weeks where we talk about
reaction rates so we'll be using
arrhenius
multiple times throughout the rest of
the semester so what is it
so the arrhenius so the general
arrhenius equation can be written
like this arrhenius he was not
in the army but this is just the general
equation
okay so let's put equation there and and
so we have k
which is some rate so equals a i'll talk
about each of these
times e the exponential of e to the
minus e
a over rt
what are these things so this is the
general equation
for the rate of some process as we're
going to see this applies to many
many processes including vacancies
okay um but this is sort of the rate so
you can think of this as
okay let's just that's the rate
of a process rate of some process
okay i mean you could think about it as
the number of times something happens
per second
that's a rate right it doesn't have to
be those units but that's like a rate
right how often does this happen
the rate of the price but now so that's
dependent on
some thing called the pre-exponential
that i will talk about
pre-exponential exponential
that is a factor that is a constant
and here we have this exponent and this
is such a beautiful
expression so this is
the average thermal energy
average kinetic energy average thermal
energy
right it's taking temperature and it's
making an energy out of it now remember
we've already talked about this before
that you know you don't get what you get
are distributions so you know this would
be t
high remember i've drawn this exact
thing and this might be t
low and this might be you know uh
this this might be uh the you know the
probability of something happening
probability of occurring
and then in this case we talked about
this as the kinetic energy of the
molecules
that's a graph we showed already but so
the but this rt
is an average but so i just want to make
sure you don't forget
this is a number this is a number
you've got at 300 degrees at a thousand
degrees you calculate a number here
but whenever you're talking about
temperature you're talking about
distributions
there's some average of the distribution
but you're always talking about
distributions
that's important for understanding
arrhenius
okay now this thing here
is called the activation energy
activation energy
and that
is the energy that you have to get over
for something to happen for the thing to
happen let's take i love this analogy of
the bookcase i'm going to draw that now
so let's suppose that you have energy
like that okay so maybe this is like
potential energy yeah let's go ahead and
say potential
energy then if i've got a bookcase
and it's very very heavy and i try and i
want to push it over
on this hinge so i want to rotate it and
and push over
then you could imagine that at some
point
it's going to look like this and then at
another point
it's going to look like this right so
this is like step one
and that's step two and that's step
three
and now i'm pushing this thing over well
this is
this is the activated state
why because it's where i've i've gotten
to the highest
energy and that's where this energy
graph is important this energy axis
this is the activated state of the
bookcase right so if i plot
the the energies
right you can say one two
three you can think about it like that
right
i've literally so because it's a
potential energy right so it's like
here's the gravitational put
here it went up a little bit right so
you can think about it just like that
and here it came back down that's why i
like this analogy because it really
gives you intuitive feeling
for what's happening here there's a
process the process is pushing the
bookcase over
that bookcase has some energy associated
with it
here and here potential energy and it's
got some energy i gotta put into it
to activate it to go from here to here
all right that's why that's called the
activation energy
that's what this e a means for the
general arrhenius equation
you're pushing the bookcase over yeah
but how are you going to push it over
well clearly you're going to run around
the room and accidentally
knock into it because that's temperature
maybe that's not a good
but if you had a lot of people running
around a bookcase
maybe once in a while they'd kind of
bang into it
thermal energy right and then maybe
another time
you increase how fast everyone's running
and and you give them more energy so now
not only are they hitting it
more frequently but they're they're
actually hitting it with more energy
they're able to give it more energy now
you make everyone run really fast
and the chances that this thing goes
through that process are higher
that's what that is that's a probability
right
just you this is what this exponential
is that was the brilliance
of what he did right so so this thermal
energy
is like you know it's it's how much it's
it's like a probability but that's why
it goes into an exponential
because when you increase temperature
again it's not just that you're
increasing
how much energy over here
right how this is like kinetic energy of
some molecules maybe
how much energy those molecules have but
you're increasing how many of them
are above some threshold so you
so you your chances
go exponentially higher well you think
if it was harder and harder to push but
it's going to go the other way too
you could have sometimes somebody might
knock it the other way
it looks kind of hard from this picture
but there's a chance
it's just that the activation energy
going this way
right going this way the activation
energy is here
e a and going this way the activation
energy
would be here so this would be ea
for let's see three to one
and this would be ea ea
for one two three
now again i am giving you the general
arrhenius
we will be coming back to this when we
do reaction rates
we will be coming back to this picture
and we will be talking about reactions
and then we'll be using that and going
to equilibrium
today i want to give you a sense for
what arrhenius is because
this is where the the equation
comes from and because if you think
about now defect formation
defect formation is an activated it's a
thermally activated process
but that's exactly the point so that's
why
if we write this down i've said this now
multiple times
the vacancy
vacaney no vacancy
is always present always
present
why because it's thermally activated
so unless i can get to t equals zero
thermally
activated
there's always a chance that i push a
vacancy into the material
there's also always a chance that the
vacancy gets pushed out
so those are happening because of
temperature
you can think about that it kind of
makes sense right atoms are moving
those are the people right there's the
people in the room
and and now all of a sudden something
happens somewhere
that allows an atom to come out
we'll talk about that in a second and
create a vacancy
now there's a chance that it can go back
too right and so
there's at some point there's an
equilibrium concentration
both of those are activate thermally
activated processes that have an
arrhenius like behavior
and so you get to
the very nice
expression for um concentration
so you can get can get yeah why not get
concentration
so the concentration at equilibrium
since vacancy formation is thermally
activated
and it's thermally deactivated there's
some you know you can
you can say well when it's activated and
deactivated in the same rates you're in
equilibrium
that's how you get a concentration and i
don't need you to know the math
but i need i this is where it comes from
the number of vacancies
divided by the total number of sites is
equal to e
to the minus e vacancy i will talk about
this
vacancy divided by
uh uh let's use rt still
our t now here's the thing about rt
let's write this down because this is
really important right
if we we talked about this before if if
i'm using rt
then if it's per mole
per mole use rt
this is the ideal gas constant right
that's not just used for ideal gases
this is used for a lot of things
that's the gas constant
gas constant that's equal to
let's see if i have down here 8.314
joules per mole kelvin
so you see if i'm working in per mole
then i use
r this is in the energy unit the
those energy units have to be the same
like
they got to cancel so if my activation
energy is in
per mole fine use the gas constant
if the activation energy is in per atom
then we just use the boltzmann constant
k bt where
the boltzmann constant is something we
have seen
it is equal to the ideal gas constant
divided by
avogadro's number remember that
avogadro's number goes in
and out atomic macroscopic worlds
so r and kb same thing
okay one thing
you know notice that's per kelvin
whenever you have
equations like this that come from
thermodynamics
which is where these things come from
there is only one temperature
unit there is no other and it is kelvin
you have to be aware of that if you see
something in celsius
it's not going to work it's got to be
kelvin
all of these equations have to use
covering okay
so that now you can see at any time you
know
anytime you see uh
an equation with an exponential what's
the first thing you want to do
i mean it's like an it's almost like a
an instinctual reaction
you see an exponential take a log don't
say anything until you
take a log right so that's an so that so
we're talking about
energy of the vacancy in a minute but if
you take a log of this
then you get that the log
of what bar n b and n
well i'll talk about that equals
log of n
let's do it this way minus log of n
equals
e uh vacancy
okay uh divided by rt
that's just taking an exponential a
logarithm of this equation
and now i can talk about these n v and n
so nv
is this is literally a concentration
this is the concentration of vacancies
that are forming in my crystal
why did i get this expression and the
and notice the constant
cancelled this pre-exponential factor
cancelled it canceled because
i'm taking a concentration i'm looking
at the rate going one way and the rate
going the other
and i get to take a ratio of those that
leads me to this
this expression that's how you get from
arrhenius rates to some concentration
okay but you still but notice it's still
we call this arrhenius-like because it's
still an exponential dependence
it's not a rate it's a concentration
it's okay it's a concentration in
equilibrium
so this would be like the number of
vacancies
number of vacancies and this one
here n would be like the number of sites
number of lattice sites so it's like
you know uh concentration laticites
right
and what is this this is exactly
here here we go i have my crystal
okay here's my crystal and
here it is i think i'll stop here and
now i did this
we're going to go graphical and this
and this
that energy is literally the energy
difference it's literally the energy
difference between
having a vacancy and not having a
vacancy how much energy
question is there
yes sir oh yes there is yes there is
thank you very much
yes so that's okay so now
the energy difference between having a
vacancy and not is the vacancy formation
energy
e vacancy now sometimes and this is
unfortunate but sometimes
you will see the the vacancy formation
energy written
as the activation energy that's fine i
mean it just
it's written that way uh to get across
the point that it's an arrhenius-like
behavior
but actually the act but if you're clear
about it
and that's why i want to go through the
bookcase example right
the formation energy which is this
energy of the vacancy forming is the
difference between here
and here the activation energy
is this hill that you got to get over to
go back and forth okay
so so the formation energy between
having a vacancy and not is what goes
into our
our equation all right now we're going
to use this so
so we will see how this works in just a
few minutes
um but again there are so many processes
that are thermally activated there are
so many processes
that have arrhenius like behavior
that are iranian-like and if you go to
dartmouth then
they'll give you goodie bags with live
crickets and actually i really hope not
but this is one of the labs that they
have where they take crickets
and they measure the number of times a
cricket chirps
and and they're like well okay let's
measure the cricket chirp
over 13 seconds we're going to cool them
down hopefully not
too cold and then we're going to heat
them up hopefully not too hot
because crickets are nice right
and and so then and they ca but look at
that and they count it and then what do
they do
well they didn't know about iranius yet
until somebody
from mit went and visited so the first
thing they did
is they plotted the data look at that
chirps per
13 seconds plotted and they're all
sitting there trying to fit a straight
line to it
and and then someone from this class is
up there busy they're like you know what
i think this looks like a thermally
activated process so i think it's
probably exponential
and then they fit this nice exponential
and it fits the
the cricket tripping beautifully
and you can go even further because you
see
if you got this far
well now you see this is a line this is
a line and we're going to do that
a lot when we go into reaction kinetics
if you have a
exponential and you take a log that's a
line versus 1 over t
right that's a line versus 1 over t and
so that's another way you could look at
data they didn't do it there
but you know you could plot for example
you could plot 1 over t
versus the log of
the number of vacancies
but the lattice the number of vacancies
is what we want
that ratio is the concentration that
concentration is in equilibrium at some
temperature
okay the lattice the number of lattice
sites is simply how many laticites you
have in whatever volume you have
for whatever crystal structure you have
for whatever element you have
we'll see that in a few examples so
that's just a concert
it's the number of sites you have in the
chunk of material and then instead of
the question this equation tells you the
answer to is how many of those
have a vacancy because it's a thermally
activated process
and if you plot that log in
the versus temperature you get this
really nice
linear line and the slope
of that line is equal to
minus e vacancy
divided by uh r or
or it could be kb r let's
write this again per mole
or or it could be kb
if it's per atom you will see both
you will see both and this this
intercept
intercept
is equal to the
let's see the intercept is equal what do
i have here the
the log of n did i write it right
log of n
okay all right
now um okay oh yeah what else can you do
well before we go on to the defects this
explains the doping
but i kept calling the doping in
semiconductors a thermally
activated process but look at what
happens
this is the carrier concentration in
that
conduction band the thing you've been
you've been learning about right and
thinking about
but look at it now versus temperature
it's a straight line
it's a straight line this is this is
experimentally what you observe
and the reason is because it's a
thermally activated process and in fact
in this case
what is the activation energy right the
activation energy
for getting an electron into the
conduction band
is the gap right and so then now you say
germanium has a smaller gap than silicon
which has a smaller gap than gallium
arsenide
the slopes are different the slopes are
different
because the energy that it takes in that
activated process
is the gap that's why the slopes are
different
right okay all right now on to
oh no i didn't i didn't want to mention
this because it's so cool
so what somebody said where are these
vacancies
going did you actually just take an atom
from the middle of a crystal and remove
it
no because that would cost way too much
energy
right and so instead they have to you
call out to the surface
it's a call out to the surface or you
know maybe the surface calls in
it all has to happen on the surface so
what ends up happening is a surface atom
may go away
and then another one may take its place
right
and and then the next one and then the
next one and that's literally how you
can rip an atom out from somewhere
inside
but by the same that's that's literally
pushing the bookcase over
right and now you can push it the other
way and
and the same a surface atom could go in
to the crystal so that some atom inside
is able to fill
a vacancy it all comes to the surface
this is a beautiful paper
where they're showing how you get these
rings this was published
almost 20 years ago now but how you know
they're studying how do vacancies
actually pull atoms from the surface
specifically
and what they did is they change the
temperature and they see islands growing
and shrinking where are those islands
going
and where are they coming from vacancies
it's all about the vacancies
right and one of the things i loved
about this is this is the abstract of
this paper
look at this here we show the vacancy
generation
and annihilation right both ways on the
1-1-0
surface of an ordered nickel aluminum
inter-metallic alloy
oh i love reading that because you guys
all are experts in this now you know
what that means
you know what that means where do
vacancies come from okay
and now we got to make vacancies right
and so this is the kind of problem you
might get
how many vacancies are in a centimeter
cubed of copper
how many how many vacancies are in a
centimeter cubed of copper
well now you know how to do it you're
just going to apply
this arrhenius-like behavior you're
going to apply this
equation to
figure that out and i won't go through
all the math but i do want to just
give you a sense of the types of
questions that you can now answer
that you know
how to think about vacancy formation
so for example in this one you've got
step one step one you would find
n
step one you'd find n how many sites do
i have
because remember this equation is about
a concentration between the number of
vacancies and the number of available
sites for vacancies
and so step one well so step one you'd
say
n equals avogadro's number
times 8.4 grams per mole
right divided by all this is such
old-school stuff right now right
grams per mole then you look that up in
the periodic table
and it's 8 times 10 to the 22nd
uh sites
per centimeter cubed
why am i using centimeter cube well
because that's what i was given the
density in so i'm just leaving it in
those units for now
right and then step two
you can find nv
so now we can apply our
our equation and v equals
uh n i won't repeat it times
e now i've got my
kb instead of r
so it's 9.9 electron volts divided by
and then this is k b t
now i get so i'm given that it's
uh a thousand wait a second what's the
term oh a thousand degrees so do i put t
equals a thousand
no no you never use
you only use kelvin 1273
right t is always in kelvin for any of
these thermodynamic
uh equations and i won't go through the
math but it goes something like 2.2
times 10 to the 19th
vacancies i'll write the units here just
for completeness
vacancies per centimeter cubed
now that seems like a lot but it's
actually now you say it's like one in a
thousand or one in ten thousand atoms
are missing
and i'm at a really high temperature if
i were at then this is the power of what
irenaeus gave us
if because it's exponential it's all
about probabilities and sampling and how
many times did i bump into that bookcase
if i'm down at room temperature i've got
so much less energy and so many more
chances
so many fewer chances to deliver that
energy
right where the surface is taking atoms
in and out to create vacancies
that at room temperature the number of
vacancies is
10 to the seventh instead of 10 to the
19th
right so that's the power of that
exponential that's the power of the
exponential
you might also be asked questions like
this one right so oh no
like let me do this one then i'll talk
about your goodie bag where
instead of now okay what example two
what is the vacancy formation energy in
aluminum and now
notice instead of giving you the vacancy
formation energy
per atom i'm giving you other stuff
i'm actually giving you how many
vacancies you got
at some temperature well that's this
just going in a different direction
to say but it's using the same math so
you can go in different ways arrive at
the same kinds of equations and get all
of these
things and i won't go through the
details
but ins in this case uh you get that e
a equals minus
k b t i'm using kb because look at that
the formation energy asked is what is
the vacancy formation energy
okay well actually look at that no i
just want to do it per atom
it didn't say per atom but if i wanted
to do a paradigm i'd use kbt
times log nb over n
and so you see 0.75
ev per atom now
what's injury like copper was
copper was 0.9 aluminum .75
you're going to have a lot more
vacancies
because it's exponential this seems like
0.9.75 is kind of the same
no it's going into an exponential so it
has a really big difference on how many
vacancies you have
at any given temperature aluminum is
going to have a lot more because it's
easier
to get them in there right
notice i did the thing that i said other
people do and i don't really like that's
the energy of the vacancy
they can see formation
people call it activation energy all
over the place
okay now this this is your goody bag now
why am i giving because
first of all this is the most
sophisticated vacancy generation machine
you'll ever
find there are exactly 500 beads in this
exactly there are not 501 there are not
499
and you know why because laura has spent
7 000 hours
counting beads in every single one of
these so you have exactly the right
number
then there's precision tape and
polycarbonate films
maybe and um and what you guys can do is
build your own
crystal it's a 2d crystal here's what's
so cool about this
try to get those vacancies out so i look
look at this
dude none of you can see what i'm
talking about
there's a big vacancy there i've
literally made this
right in front of me this is here
and and now i'm gonna say okay i'll use
temperature
there's so many more there's so many
more
because i use temperature this is
temperature
you are temperature and you can run
around
and you can shake it and all you bring
it to the dance floor
and and then you're like how can i get
whoa wait a second
i'll just quietly go down in temperature
and i'll get rid of them
yeah tell that to your friends down the
street see
how long they go until they stop trying
because you guys know
not to try because you'll never get rid
of them you'll
never get rid of them you'll always have
vacancies and this is proof
that you will always have vacancies you
can try to tap it like that
see if you can get rid of the defects
you can't
luckily that's a good thing because
defects are what make everything
interesting
everything this is your goody bag
so you can touch and feel but we got to
cover the other case
because see i could have had
not just a metal where every atom is the
same
but i could have had an ionic solid you
can make point defects in ionic solids
as well
right so yeah so if i had a defect
in an ionic solid well now you got to
consider the charge
i can't just keep pulling it is sodium
chloride i can't just keep pulling out
like one type of atom if i take a sodium
atom out like imagine that it's a plus
minus plus minus right the size is if i
take a sodium atom out
then it becomes charged because remember
the ionic bond is
one of them grabbed it and it has it and
so if i take one out i've charged the
crystal you can't do that
it won't let you so if i take a sodium
atom out a chlorine is going to come too
it's got to come too
you got to keep it charged neutral if it
starts charging neutral so
these have special names because of that
and there are two types of defects in
ionic so
point defects we're still with point
defects
local disruption in the regularity
one is called the shocky defect right
so in the shocky defect
you got both
an anion and a cation are removed
cation now here's the thing i should
have put
s because you may need to take more than
one out
all right removed
and because you got to ensure
ensure charge
neutrality charge neutrality
so like you know if i had so inquiry
that's fine but what if i had
um you know something else what if i had
instead of sodium chloride
what if i had like calcium chloride so
now what if i had calcium
chloride well that looks like that
because calcium goes to two plus
we know this right but chlorine is only
minus
one so that ionic crystal is different
and what it means is that if i remove
if i remove
a calcium it's going to come out as ca2
plus but that means
i need
to remove two
cl minus atoms
that's the thing about shocking defects
you got to keep the charge balance so
so now it's not just a one for one
this could actually be a way to take
atoms out or if i want to take
chlorine out of this it'll take some
calcium out
chlorine will come out too right could
be a way to engineer it
so that's a that's a shockity but the
simpler thing that could have happened
is just that one of these atoms kind of
moved over so
so now i didn't remove it from the
crystal
but it just kind of wandered over into
some site
so like you know here's bcc you know i
can't have like
an an atom so this i mean this doesn't
look
like a an ionic solid but suppose it
doesn't matter i could have an atom
leave a site and go notice that there
are these voids
right they're these spaces in between
other atoms
well those spaces are places where atoms
can can go
they're not it's not part of the regular
lattice but it's it's just it's like a
hole
right remember the the packing fractions
we never got above about three quarters
we never got about three good that means
there's still a bunch of volume in there
that's free volume right where is it
well
this kind of defect will find it right
so you could have the smaller
ion migrate over create a vacancy
and it's going to find a place where it
likes to go
ah okay yeah we'll do this
and so
so that's called a frankel defect
so frankel defect is the other kind of
special name we give to a vacancy
in an ionic solid and
it's where one ion right an ion ion or
cation
anion or cation
moves
to some open space open
space in the lattice
and you can already kind of feel where
this might be kind of common
it might be common in situations where
you've got a big size difference
right so like the silver halides are a
good example like
silver chloride silver
bromide silver iodide
those are all good examples because
what happens there is this ionic
structure has a very big mismatch
between the atom sizes
and and so you can see let's blow up a
picture of this is silver iodide a
cartoon
look at that so those are the silver
atoms and what you see is because
there's such a big difference in size
you're gonna have these pretty big voids
and one of the atoms is small enough
that it actually doesn't mind it's
actually pretty easy
to move it ah now if you think about it
well if you have enough vacancies in
there
then maybe those ions can actually move
really freely
because they're so small and the voids
are all kind of nearby
and and you actually can get a conductor
a good conductor
this way you're creating vacancies on
purpose
so that one of the ions can move around
the smaller one
right that's what we do we make these
solid-state ionic conductors
you need the vacancies you need the
vacancies okay
now i told you that uh we got this
this map here we've talked about
literally just one luckily i don't have
nearly the same amount of material to
talk about these others the vacancy is
clearly the one
that i'm very interested in the subs
the self-interstitial is actually pretty
easy to understand
the self-interstitial is actually pretty
easy to understand because it simply
doesn't really happen much
and and and the reason is if you look at
this here's a picture
of is basically what i drew on the board
right but now
i've put so these are this is this is
not a vacancy
right this is a kind of point defect but
it's not a vacancy i've actually
added an atom into the lattice and i've
squeezed it in between all the others
you can just
feel how much energy how much strain
those other atoms are gonna have to make
and how much energy that's going to cost
those are high energy defects so so a
self-interstitial
a self-interstitial self just means it's
the same atom as the rest of them
is very infrequent is very infrequent
the self-interstitial let's see i'll
just use this one again
the self-interstitial has an energy of
formation of something like you know
five electron volts
anything but you know five electron
volts
self-interstitial self-interstitial
it went in between so it's not
substitutional
it's interstitial and itself because
it's the same atom type
the energy energy of formation
is 5ev i think 5ev doesn't even sound
that much higher than like the one ev
you had for copper
right 0.9 ev but it goes into the
exponential
right so it's like one per
centimeter cubed literally you get like
one of these happening
per centimeter cubed instead of 10 to
the 20th or 10 to the 10th or
you know many many orders of magnitude
higher so the self-interstitial is
actually not very interesting
it's actually not very interesting now
because we have
uh like half a minute left i'm not gonna
talk about these we'll have a very brief
discussion about these last two types of
point defects and then we're gonna make
line defects on wednesday and my why
this matters i'll give you on wednesday
for this
you